NOW, YOU ALWAYS HEAR POLITICIANS
SAYING THEY WANT TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT RACE.
YEAH.
(LAUGHTER)
BUT WHEN THEY ACTUALLY HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION, THINGS TEND
TO GET A LITTLE AWKWARD.
>> NEW VIDEO REVEALS WHAT
HAPPENED BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
WHEN HILLARY CLINTON AND MEMBERS
OF BLACK LIVES MATTER MET ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
>> Larry: OOH!
A VIDEO!
(LAUGHTER)
YEAH.
THIS IS GOING TO BE JUICY.
ALL RIGHT.
TO HELP ME NAVIGATE THROUGH
THIS, FROM HRC HEADQUARTERS IS
HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN
OFFICIAL CARLOS JORDANSON.
>> HOW YOU DOING?
>> Larry: CARLOS, WELCOME TO THE
SHOW.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
AND ALL THE WAY FROM
BLACK HEADQUARTERS, PLEASE
WELCOME "NIGHTLY SHOW"
CONTRIBUTOR HOLLY WALKER.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
SO HOLLY, YOU'RE AT BLACK
HEADQUARTERS?
>> YES.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: WHAT ARE YOU DOING
THERE?
(LAUGHTER)
>> I'M HERE TO MONITOR HOW THE
BLACK VOTE IS RESPONDING TO
HILLARY WHEN SHE'S CONFRONTED
ABOUT RACE, USING THE
STATE-OF-THE-ART NWA.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: NWA?
>> YES, LARRY.
THE NEGROMETRIC WAVE
ACCELERATOR.
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: OH.
OKAY.
I NEVER HEARD OF THAT.
>> YEAH.
AND SO FAR, HER NUMBERS ARE
UNDERWATER.
(LAUGHTER)
AND I'M NOT GETTING MY HAIR
WET TO GO SAVE HER.
>> Larry: OKAY.
(LAUGHTER)
I GET IT.
I UNDERSTAND.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT, WHY DON'T WE
LOOK AT THE FIRST CLIP?
>> OKAY.
>> AMERICA'S FIRST DRUG IS FREE
BLACK LABOR AND TURNING BLACK
BODIES INTO PROFIT.
>> MM-HMM.
>> AND THE MASS INCARCERATION
SYSTEM MIRRORS AN AWFUL LOT LIKE
THE PRISON PLANTATION SYSTEM.
>> MM-HMM.
(LAUGHTER)
>> OKAY, LARRY, I WANT TO STOP
IT RIGHT HERE.
>> Larry: OKAY.
>> I'VE JUST SEEN A SPIKE IN THE
METER.
>> Larry: REALLY?
>> YEAH.
I'M GOING TO ATTRIBUTE IT TO
HILLARY'S "MM-HMMs."
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: WAIT, HER "MM-HMMs"?
>> MM-HMM.
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: OKAY.
WHAT DID YOU NOTICE?
>> YEAH.
WELL, THEY STARTED OFF NERVOUS.
BUT NOW SHE'S DOING EXACTLY WHAT
BLACK PEOPLE LIKE, LETTING
SOMEBODY KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
THINKING BY MAKING AN
AFFIRMATIVE NOISE.
>> Larry: MM-HMM!
>> MM-HMM.
(LAUGHTER)
>> EXACTLY.
EXACTLY.
(APPLAUSE)
>> LARRY, I'D LIKE TO TAKE
CREDIT FOR THIS, IF I MAY.
>> Larry: SURE.
>> THIS WAS ALL PART OF OUR
"MM-HMM" ROLLOUT.
(LAUGHTER)
HILLARY IS REACHING THE BLACK
COMMUNITY ONE "MM-HMM" AT A
TIME.
>> Larry: OKAY.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
LOOK, WE'RE GOING TO JUMP
FORWARD A LITTLE BIT.
THERE WAS A VERY AWKWARD MOMENT
AFTER THEY MADE IT CLEAR TO
HILLARY AFTER THEY HELD HER
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE MASS
INCARCERATIONS OF BLACK MEN IN
THE '90s BASED ON THE CRIME
BILL IN 1994 THAT HER HUSBAND
SIGNED AND SHE CHAMPIONED.
>> HOW DO YOU ACTUALLY FEEL
THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN YOU DID
BEFORE?
FOR A MOMENT OF REFLECTION ON
HOW WE TREAT BLACK PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY?
>> MM-HMM.
MM-HMM.
>> I JUST WANT TO -- AND I
APOLOGIZE -- IN -- IN -- WE
HAVE --
>> I WOULD REALLY LOVE TO ALLOW
HER TO ANSWER THIS QUESTION.
>> Larry: WHOA!
WHAT IS HER HANDLER DOING?
LET HER TALK!
IS SHE GOING TO GET OUT OF --
THIS IS SOME [ BLEEP ], LARRY.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: WAIT.
HOLD UP --
CARLOS, YOU'RE AT HILLARY'S
HEADQUARTERS.
IS THIS [ BLEEP ]?
(LAUGHTER)
>> THAT WAS CLASSIC TALK-BLOCK!
NICELY DONE, NEIL.
(LAUGHTER)
THAT WAS SO CLOSE.
HILLARY WAS ABOUT TO ACTUALLY
ANSWER A QUESTION OFF THE CUFF.
WOO!
CRISIS AVOIDED.
(LAUGHTER)
>> NO, NO, NO.
SHE NEEDS TO ANSWER THE QUESTION
IF SHE EXPECTS TO BE PRESIDENT!
>> SPEAKING OF PRESIDENTS, BLACK
LIVES MATTER, PEOPLE, YOU HAVE
ONE RIGHT NOW, IN THE WHITE
HOUSE!
GO BOTHER HIM!
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: OKAY, GUYS.
WAIT!
COME ON!
>> Larry: HOLD ON NOW, CALM
DOWN.
ACTUALLY, HILLARY DID HAVE A
CHANCE TO ANSWER, SO LET'S TAKE
A LOOK.
>> -- ALL I'M SAYING IS YOUR
ANALYSIS IS TOTALLY FAIR.
IT'S HISTORICALLY FAIR.
IT'S PSYCHOLOGICALLY FAIR.
IT'S ECONOMICALLY FAIR.
>> I FEEL A "BUT" COMING ON.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: IS SHE GOING TO "BUT"
THIS, CARLOS?
>> TECHNICALLY, LARRY, I LIKE TO
REFER TO IT AS AS
SENTENCE-TWERKING.
>> Larry: OH.
(LAUGHTER)
OKAY.
>> BUT YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
COME TOGETHER AS A MOVEMENT AND
SAY, HERE'S WHAT WE WANT DONE
ABOUT IT.
BECAUSE YOU CAN GET LIP SERVICE
FROM AS MANY WHITE PEOPLE AS YOU
CAN PACK INTO YANKEE STADIUM AND
A MILLION MORE LIKE IT WHO ARE
GOING TO SAY, OH, WE GET IT.
WE GET IT.
WE'RE GOING TO BE NICER.
OKAY?
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH.
>> YES!
YES!
YANKEE STADIUM FILLED WITH WHITE
PEOPLE!
(LAUGHTER)
THAT'S A METAPHOR.
>> Larry: I'M NOT SURE THAT'S
A METAPHOR.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE THE ACTUAL
THING.
(LAUGHTER)
HOLLY, HOW DID THAT SOUND BITE
REGISTER ON THE NEGROMETRIC WAVE
DO-HICKEY?
>> WHOA, SHE'S SPIKING.
THIS KIND OF DATA USUALLY
INDICATES BLACK PEOPLE ARE
EXPECTING A FIGHT TO BREAK OUT.
(LAUGHTER)
SERIOUSLY, LARRY.
THESE ARE "REAL HOUSEWIVES OF
ATLANTA" NUMBERS.
>> Larry: WOW.
(LAUGHTER)
THAT'S HUGE.
IT DOES APPEAR THAT HILLARY
SEEMS TO BE NOT BACKING
DOWN.
LET'S WATCH SOME MORE.
>> I SAY THIS AS RESPECTFULLY AS
I CAN, BUT IF YOU DON'T TELL
BLACK PEOPLE WHAT WE NEED TO DO,
THEN WE WON'T TELL YOU ALL WHAT
YOU NEED TO DO.
>> I'M NOT TELLING YOU.
I'M JUST TELLING YOU TO TELL ME.
>> Larry: OH!
(LAUGHTER)
[ AUDIENCE OHs ]
>> MAN!
WHAT?!
>> -- RESPECTFULLY IF THAT IS
YOUR POSITION, THEN I WILL TALK
ONLY TO WHITE PEOPLE.
>> Larry: OH!
OH!
[ AUDIENCE OOHs ]
>> NO!
>> OH, MAN!
>> Larry: WHAT'S HAPPENING ON
THE METER, HOLLY?
>> OH, MY GOSH!
THESE NUMBERS ARE OFF THE
CHARTS, LARRY!
THESE ARE WORLD STAR NUMBERS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: OKAY.
OKAY.
QUIET DOWN!
ARE YOU OKAY, CARLOS?
>> I'M FINE.
MY ULCER IS A LITTLE --
>> Larry: OKAY.
MAN!
>> Larry: LET'S SEE HOW IT ENDS.
>> LOOK, I DON'T BELIEVE YOU
CHANGE HEARTS.
I BELIEVE YOU CHANGE LAWS.
YOU CHANGE ALLOCATION OF
RESOURCES.
YOU CHANGE THE WAY SYSTEMS
OPERATE.
YOU MAY ACTUALLY CHANGE SOME
HEARTS, BUT IF THAT'S ALL THAT
HAPPENS, WE'LL BE BACK HERE IN
TEN YEARS HAVING THE SAME
CONVERSATION.
>> Larry: WOW, I DON'T THINK
I'VE EVER HEARD HILLARY TALK
LIKE THAT.
I MEAN, SO DIRECT AND AUTHENTIC.
GUYS?
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> SORRY, LARRY.
THE NEGROMETRIC WAVE ACCELERATOR
DOESN'T MEASURE AUTHENTICITY.
(LAUGHTER)
IT ONLY MEASURES [ BLEEP ] THAT
BLACK PEOPLE ARE TIRED OF
HEARING FROM POLITICIANS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: MAKES SENSE.
CARLOS?
>> SORRY, I GOT NOTHING.
>> LARRY, I'D JUST LIKE TO SAY
THIS IS ALL PART OF A CAREFULLY
ORCHESTRATED CAMPAIGN I CAME UP
WITH CALLED "AUTHENTICITY
AUGUST."
(LAUGHTER)
IT CONTINUES THIS WEEKEND IN
IOWA WHEN HILLARY WILL
"ACCIDENTALLY" GET STUCK IN
A WELL.
THERE'S NO WELL.
(LAUGHTER)
>> OH!
LOOKS LIKE THE METER'S WORKING
AGAIN.
>> Larry: OKAY, THANKS FOR
CHIMING IN, GUYS.
WE'LL SEE IF THIS UNSCRIPTED
HILLARY'S GOING TO LAST.
BUT FOR ONE NIGHT IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE AT LEAST, HILLARY
WENT BEHIND CURTAIN AND FINALLY
LIFTED THE VEIL.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)